the palestinian village of Battier lies
in the West Bank countryside near
Bethlehem these terraces have been
farmed for generations Abu husam wants
to water his fields parts of the
irrigation system date back to Roman
times
the network of canals branches out from
a spring to the villagers fields each
family in the village waters its plot at
a set time every day some in the morning
some in the evening de shakira canada
for siferra eggplants tomatoes and
zucchini is here everything you need you
come down here take what you like and
then go home I never have to go to the
market ethic motorized took over then
until now villagers here also cultivated
the fields on the other side of the
railway tracks
but Israel is planning to extend its
frontier barrier through here separating
the fields from the village locals have
been battling the decision in court for
years this is a 5,000 year old
civilization and now a barrier is going
to be built there that will destroy
everything in a matter of hours this
will destroy a piece of world cultural
heritage we had a death Ilana me israel
says its security barrier is designed to
prevent terrorist attacks the army told
DW that it's taking villagers concerns
into account in but here the defense
establishment has been particularly
careful not to damage the fabric of life
of the villagers and not to harm the
special landscape terraces it's still
unclear what form the barrier here will
take but for a boo hoo some any kind of
barrier is a problem chalkin acaba ed I
feel as though they're cutting off a
part of my body just like my hand on my
leg this land is my life they're taking
my memories away of my father's and
grandfather's land get the magic deep
Abu Hasan worries that soon he may need
special permission even to set foot on
the land beyond the railway tracks